بعد ايام من الغموض قررت الاداره
الامريكيه الاجابه على بعض الاسئله
المتكرره والمتعلقه بالاجسام المجهوله
التي تم اسقاطها في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
الاجابات لم تكن شافيه مع الاعتراف ان
الكثير من المعلومات لا زالت مجهوله
فعمليه انتشال الحطام لم تتم حتى اللحظه
كريم جون بيار المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
شددت
انا اؤكد اننا وجود لطبيعه فضائيه او
مخلوقات فضائيه متورطه بموضوع هذه الاجسام
دعوني اكرر ان لا صله بالكائنات الفضائيه
على الاطلاق
اما جون كاربي المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي فاختار توجيه الاتهامات الى اداره
الرئيس ترامب في محاوله لتحديد النظر عن
التطورات
لازلنا لا نعلم الكثير عن هذه الاجسام
ولكن ما اود الاشاره اليه فهو ان عددا من
هذه الاجسام مره فوق بلادنا والاداره
السابقه لم ترصدها نحن فعلنا ذلك رصدناها
واسقطناها الجيش الامريكي اسقط ثلاثه
اجسام مجهوله في المجال الجوي لامريكا
الشماليه في غضون ثلاثه ايام الجسم الاول
اعلن عن اسقاطه يوم الجمعه في الاسكا ما
نعرفه عنه حجمه اصغر من البالون الصيني
الاول وهو بحجم سياره صغيره
غير ماهول بالاضافه طبعا الى الجسم الثاني
الذي اسقط في كندا له شكل اسطواني واسقطته
طائره اف 23 امريكيه في الاراضي الكنديه
لنصل الى الجسم الذي اسقط يوم الاحد في
ولايه ميشيغان الامريكيه وادى لاغلاق
المجال الجوي فوق بحيره هورون وهو الاغرب
من بين الاجسام السابقه فهو هيكل مثمن
الاضلاع له خطوط متدليه ولا توجد حموله
يمكن تمييزها ولا مؤشره على امتلاكه قدرات
للمراقبه على الرغم من عدم استبعاد ذلك
وتم اسقطه من طائره اف 16 امريكيه
الغموض يؤجج نظريات المؤامره بشكل كبير
فموضوع الاجسام المشغوله ثلاثه حكومات حتى
اللحظه بالاضافه الى اغلاق المجال الجوي
لاربع ولايات امريكيه على ما دعده ايام
واليوم الصين تتحدث عن رصدها لجسم مجهول
فوق منطقه البحر الاصفر الذي اعتبرته
واحدا من عشرات البالونات الامريكيه التي
رصدتها منذ 2022
من غير المرجح ان هذا صحيح لو رصدت السين
سابقا هذه الاجسام لكانت اسقطتها وعرضتها
واستخدمت كل القنوات الدبلوماسيه لتقدم
شكوى ضد الولايات المتحده في الامم
المتحده ومجلس الامن منذ لحظه اكتشافها
تبقى تداعيات رصد هذه الاجسام مرتبطه
بالحطام الذي تحاول السلطات الامريكيه
الحصول عليه فحتى اللحظه عمليه الانتشار
تواجه معوقات كثيره مثل الطقس والمساحات
الجغرافيه الواسعه بالاضافه الى الدمار
الذي يمكن ان يكون لاحقها جراء قصفها
بالصواريخ
ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن